I actually started doing this a very  long time ago it's probably like five  years ago and it started off real real  small and it just kind of like  developed into what it is today I'm from  Dallas Texas and you know we have a uh  the culture there when it comes to  haircuts where this fully Fades or uh or  or shags or or the South Side fade or  whatever man I've been doing crazy  haircut haircuts my whole entire life  and I've had this for a while it's crazy  how I got you know so much Pub right now  so since we're here we might as well  talk about it it started off you know  about six years ago with a little you  know itty bitty triangle and it just  grew and um now it has like a meaning  behind it it means uh three generations  my dad my brother and me also it means  uh  staying neutral  or positive but never negative now I'm  just joking out I was just joking I just  came up with that man it's just it's  just my haircut man and um I just wanted  to do something unique